our next guest has been in our lives
since she was a little girl with movies
like how the grinch stole christmas and
shows like gossip girl
she's also a very talented musician her
band is called the pretty reckless
they're nominated for two
i heart radio awards they're the only
female fronted band nominated in their
categories rather and their latest album
hit number one on the rock charts which
is so
cool for a chick i'm just saying it's
called death by rock and roll let's say
hello to taylor moms and everybody
hey kelly how are you i am so good i'm
so proud of you i don't even know you
that was so cool
on the rock charts that rarely happens
for women let's be real
unfortunately is uh yeah a rarity
yeah and uh and and i believe you know
death by rock and roll we actually just
said
and well death by rock and roll the
single
went number one which is crazy in covid
um
to put out a song and have it go number
one and not be able to play it live
and then our our latest single and so it
went
which features the amazing tomorrowland
also just reached number one so that i
believe that makes it our sixth number
one single at
the rock format which so yeah so i think
we're breaking
records like i think we not totally so
sorry
you're not even able to like play this
like that the energy when you get a
number one song and you're playing live
and like
ah i'm so sorry that sucks kovid
yeah well yeah you know but what you
gonna do we're all in the same boat so
we're just hanging in being patient and
like and just
so thankful and so grateful to all the
fans and like everyone who's listened
and
um and radio stations like everyone has
played it like it's just
it's absolutely incredible to see it and
and i've now like i'm trying to become
like a tech
type person i'm still really bad at it
that's why i'm being honest um but i've
now discovered that there's these things
called like reaction videos online
where you can like watch people wat
watch people videotape themselves
listening
to a song or your song for the first
time
yeah and it's not even about what they
say but like watching their face
as they listen to it i found very um
enjoyable and so like in you know in
lieu of a
massive audience in front of you like
that's that's been something that i've
it's the next like a hobby of mine yeah
it feels like it's like okay people are
listening to it it's like a show in some
form in my head my brain moving
but what was the process like for this
album because it was it different than
the other recording the other albums i
mean it was different yeah i mean it was
different in a lot of ways i mean not to
get too heavy
uh but you know we went through a lot of
loss in the past few years
um so to sorry to make a very long story
short i felt
very dark into a whole of like you know
depression and you know everything that
comes with
loss and trauma and grief and um and i
wasn't really sure how to get out of it
and um and it was me and
really as cliche as it may sound it was
music like music was the thing that
really
brought me back to life and like brought
like the sparkle back into my eyes
and um it's therapeutic
super therapeutic and and the writing of
record
it just like the floodgates opened and
this record kind of like just wrote
itself whether i wanted it to or not
um i didn't really have a choice in the
matter and i wasn't even thinking about
like recording it or
putting it out or like i wasn't thinking
that far ahead it just it just
flowed and i think that that makes for
something that's really special and
you know even the title death by rock
and roll which i know
can sound very morbid to a lot of people
just because of the title you know just
because of the word death
um is not like death by rock and roll it
was this it was this
motto and this ethic and this this
you know lifestyle that it was like live
your life by
of you know live life your own way go
out your own way don't let anyone tell
you differently don't let anyone tell
you how to live like
freedom so it's like very much a battle
cry for life
itself and so that phrase like just
started to resonate in my head in a way
in a in a way that i couldn't ignore i
guess and and
and in a in a new way i guess um
you know i hope people can relate to
that and maybe kind of find some solace
in it the same way i found solace and
in the records that i grew up loving and
listening to and like and
you know finding that comfort and
knowing that you know
absolutely yeah knowing that you're not
alone
yeah well thank you so much taylor it's
great to meet you i cannot wait to hear
this whole
record yep i'm still here just waiting
for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever